burning fossil fuels like this lump of
coal releases the energy we use to power
our modern world it also produces carbon
dioxide a greenhouse gas that's why in a
couple of weeks well leaders are meeting
in Paris to make a deal that will
determine the future of our climate
their aim to stop the world warming up
by more than two degrees compared to
before the Industrial Revolution so why
two degrees what's so special about this
level well the hope is that this limit
would avoid large potentially
irreversible changes to our ecosystem
things like the complete melting of the
Greenland ice sheet which could
eventually lead to seven meters of sea
level rise that's more than twice the
height of this fence but no amount of
warming is safe some scientists and
policymakers recommend one and a half
degrees would be a better bet others
reckon the global temperature is too
simple a measure of the Earth's
well-being but for now it's the target
we've got so how do we hit it the more
carbon we burn the hotter it gets that
means a limit of two degrees also limits
the amount of carbon we can burn to have
a good chance of staying under two
degrees that limits us to burning about
a trillion tons of carbon ever that
might sound like loads but let's say
this is the trillion tons of carbon
well then we've already burnt about this
much since the 1850s that means all the
other carbon we know about that's this
pile about two and a half trillion tons
has to stay in the ground if we're going
to stay below two degrees but at this
rate we're gonna have burnt through this
pile this crucial trillion ton limit in
just 20 years
so who gets to burn the last fossil
fuels how do we make sure the rest stays
in the ground and what does world that's
two degrees warmer look like that's what
leaders are meeting in Paris to try to
work out
you
you